another thing we're seeing globally is
really globalization on the wane we see
this politically in country after
country again you can go back to brexit
you can go back to what's being talked
about in France and go back to this
country
the United States do you believe that
globalization really is on the way down
has it peaked and what are the
consequences of that oh it is basically
what you're seeing now that China which
was a key vehicle in that process now
pulling back and it's starting to it you
know the yuan is was been weakening
fairly significantly and the reason
essentially is that the structure is
changing there is an inconsistency in
the Chinese system in which they're
trying to become a capitalist economy
and indeed in certain respects they're
becoming the largest capitalist economy
in the world the problem is you cannot
do that in a single-party state and
we're beginning to run up against the
edge in short as you know the yuyuan has
been weakened very significantly and we
used to say well they're manipulating
their currency they are not manipulating
it in the direction people think they're
trying to support it and it's getting
out of hand and these controls are being
put in place are essentially an
indication that when you have a
single-party state they can move very
quickly and they do and what we're
seeing is the consequences of a real
attempt to become an international
currency which would have reached its
peak when au here so low when they
looked as though they were going to
become a very big deal and everyone was
going to be trading in any one RMB
instead of
our no and there's no evidence of that's
going to do continue is it fair to say
that China does do its best whether
successful or not to try to adjust the
level of Iran I don't think that the
issue everybody is manipulating their
France is not it that's the problem
we're all culprits but it's a zero-sum
game so it's not to answer that question
because of it that used to be a
meaningful meaningful question 15 years
ago I don't think it really is related
as a significant issue anymore